as we continue with pet week like humans
we know that our pets need not just
exercise but the thing that
sometimes we find in short supply and
that's sleep a good sleep and exercise
regime is going to help make a
healthier and happier dog pet
trandologist charlotte reed business
once again
some great ideas about dogs and sleeping
hi charlotte
hi nate how are you i'm sticking with
mostly sunny your honor but
i wanted to find out how many hours a
day do dogs sleep anyway
dogs generally sleep 18 to 14 hours a
day but that a lot
that depends a lot on age activity
activity level as well as health
okay now i know that humans can
sometimes get sleep disorders do dogs
have those too
believe it or not dogs can get sleep
disorders too a lot of dogs suffer some
insomnia and generally the dogs who
suffer from insomnia or dogs that are
ill they might have arthritis they can't
get comfortable so they're up and down
all night
sometimes if they have breathing issues
respiratory or heart problems they do
they also can suffer from sleep apnea
and you find that a lot with
dogs that are really overweight or
actually snug those dogs like wally
and hammy here their english choice
manual so your boxers your pugs
your english bulldogs a lot of times
they have sleep apnea
as well as believe it or not some dogs
suffer from narcolepsy and a lot of
times that's genetics so
one of the big breeds that suffers from
that is actually
doberman pinscher all of a sudden
they'll be standing and they'll just
fall over
so can we do anything about that yeah
you could talk to your veterinarian but
like i said a lot of time it's a genetic
disorder
the most important thing is are really
having a great
healthy routine you know feeding your
dog at the same time having him play
and that a lot depends on the weather
whether you're in a cold environment or
you're in a warm environment
so getting them to get as much sleep as
possible kind of like humans do
and you know we're different i mean
humans tend to sleep in one big cycle
you know anywhere from five to eight
hours a day where dogs sleep throughout
the day and then we try to get them to
sleep when we go to sleep
no i've you know i think we've all seen
our pets whether it's dogs or cats
they're kind of like twitching a little
bit is that's just normal they're just
dreaming right
a lot of times they are dreaming i mean
they're in that deep rem cycle
you never want to wake up a dog when
he's in that rem cycle what you
if you do have to wake up your dog you
want to call him you know call his name
hammy wally and see if they pay
attention or you want to go over them
very very gently i had one english toy
spaniel
you would swear he would go hide
somewhere i'd call him he'd never come
out
and he was like i would go over and he'd
be like sleeping like he was dead
and i would just very gently pet them
juggle them just a little bit very very
gently
because you don't know what they're
dreaming about you don't want them to
turn around wake up and turn around and
bite you
and that's a lot of times what happens
with young children they go over they
get really excited and they really
jostle the dog and the dog will wake up
and turn around and bite them because he
won't remember what's going on
oh my goodness well charlotte these are
some incredible tips and we're glad to
meet your two new pet pals that you have
with us here
we always enjoy talking with you
unfortunately we're out of time for
today
but keep up those great tips and we'll
talk to you again real soon
thank you bye everybody charlotte reed
everybody
thank you